this video was made possible by
brilliant start learning with brilliant
for 20 off by being one of the first 200
to sign up at brilliant.org
wendover political alliances manifest
themselves here
on the voting floor of the united
nations general assembly in new york new
york
in this room countries impose
legislation that carries weight
worldwide
and so what happens in this room is the
physical materialization of the world's
politics
47 years ago exactly that happened when
one of the general assembly's most
consequential votes occurred
china you see essentially has two
governments
there's the republic of china which used
to control the mainland and taiwan but
today
only administers taiwan and there's the
people's republic of china which
controls the mainland
both claimed to be the rightful
governments of all of the chinese
territory
both taiwan and the mainland and so back
in 1971
the united nations had to decide which
government would represent china
essentially the question was which
government was the rightful leader of
the territory
as there could only be one in the united
nations the u.s was the main superpower
opposing the people's republic
representing china as it had a strong
political and military alliance with the
republic of china government
and so the vote was essentially the us's
sphere of influence
versus the world among the 35 countries
that voted against the people's republic
were much of africa
the central african republic chad gabon
liberia
niger south africa and plenty of others
that sided with the us
despite the us's effort the resolution
ended up passing and the representative
government for china in the u.n was
switched to the people's republic of
china
but what's interesting about this vote
is not the result it's who voted
against the people's republic since that
1971 vote you see
something has changed in 2007
the un general assembly met once again
to vote on whether to adopt a resolution
condemning the human rights situation in
north korea
as one of north korea's strongest allies
this vote was china and its fear of
influence
versus the world in this vote though
only burundi
equatorial guinea eritrea ghana kenya
lesotho
liberia madagascar malawi mauritania and
tanzania
voted against china all the 43 other
african countries either abstained or
voted no
along with china because in the 40 years
between these votes
political ties changed africa no longer
bows to the us
much of the continent is now
economically and politically aligned
with the world's fastest emerging
superpower china the simple answer for
why this is is because china has pumped
huge amounts of money into the continent
of africa
they're buying allies for example china
built a 3.2 billion
railway in kenya trekking the 300 miles
from nairobi the capital to mombasa the
second largest city and primary port
in 4 hours and 30 minutes that's faster
than what the fastest train in the u.s
the acela express takes to travel the
equivalent distance from philadelphia to
boston
china also built a 526 million
dam in guinea which helped push the
country from having constant power
shortages
to making more energy than it needs and
selling the extra capacity to its
neighbors
china also built a 475 million dollar
light rail system
in addis ababa ethiopia the first of its
kind in sub-saharan africa
designed as a way to combat the
capital's crippling traffic these are
only
a sampling there are literally hundreds
of others of chinese infrastructure
projects in africa
each year all across the continent china
is playing a part in projects both big
and small
they're transforming african economies
it's important to note that these
projects are not though
free each of these three were financed
by loans granted by china's state-owned
and controlled export-import bank
and these loans do of course need to be
paid back by the countries granted them
large african infrastructure projects
though would be viewed as risky by any
traditional bank
and would therefore struggle to get
financed but china's export-import bank
doesn't care assuming cooperation
between the chinese and african
countries governments
this bank will give low-interest or
no-interest loans to african countries
so they can build these trains or dams
or other projects
these loans are therefore considered a
form of foreign aid since china doesn't
expect to get all their money back
at least adjusted for inflation since
they're not charging much interest and
there's a high risk of default
of course china isn't just financing
these projects out of kindness
for each of them there's a political
goal behind it you see the country of
china is running out of growth potential
its era of double-digit year-over-year
gdp growth is over as it makes the shift
from industrializing
to industrialized africa meanwhile is
one of the least developed areas of the
world
and a lack of development actually makes
fast growth
easy the first step of economic
development for many countries is
natural resource exploitation
nearly every country has some level of
natural resources that can be used to
kickstart growth
but first they need to have enough money
to build the infrastructure and take the
steps needed to gather these natural
resources
as everyone knows it takes money to make
money and china
has money by investing in african mining
and farming
china can profit off africa's growth and
fuel the business back in china that
requires minerals and food
but in addition to serving as a source
of natural resources
africa has another resource labor it
might seem strange that china the
country that the world uses for low-cost
manufacturing
is looking for a labor source elsewhere
but that is exactly what it's doing
china is a victim of its own success the
economic development that its
manufacturing industry brought
pushed a large segment of its population
into the middle class which raised labor
costs countrywide
it's not bad news china as a country has
shifted from having a low-skilled to a
medium-skilled workforce as their
education level has improved
but for the lowest cost lowest skilled
manufacturing work
the country of china is no longer
competitive therefore
chinese manufacturing firms are setting
up their own operations in africa
one of the cheapest and lowest skilled
labor markets in the world
today china is now the largest trading
partner with africa as a whole
despite china being a vastly larger
country than the us in population
the u.s and china both trade a similar
value of goods worldwide each year
in this case though whereas 48 billion
dollars worth of goods were exchanged
between the us and africa in 2016
china traded 128 billion dollars worth
of goods
nearly three times as much now the whole
idea of setting up a structure of power
over other less developed states in
order to gather resources and use their
labor force
might sound familiar because that's
largely what colonialism was
the motives behind european powers
expanding their territory to less
developed nations in the 15th through
20th centuries
were remarkably similar to the
motivations between china's growing
economic influence
in the developing world today despite
what some may say
there is empirical evidence that china
has been using these infrastructure
investments to affect worldwide politics
it's been found that if an african
country recognizes taiwan as a country
they receive on average 2.7 fewer
chinese infrastructure projects within
their borders each year
conversely if an african country votes
overwhelmingly along with china in the
united nations general assembly
they receive 1.8 more infrastructure
projects each year considering that the
general assembly is an equal
representative body where each country
gets one vote no matter if they have a
million residents or a billion
china is getting a lot of influence for
in the grand scheme of things
not a lot of money china touts the fact
that their foreign
investment and aid is no strings
attached unlike other institutions that
give
low or no interest loans to developing
countries like the international
monetary fund or world bank
china gives loans with no requirements
on factors like respect of human rights
or democratic elections
of course this data linking
infrastructure investment with political
leanings shows that there
are indeed hidden strings that require
benefit for china
rather than benefit for the receiving
country western powers are
understandably concerned about this
shift in power dynamics towards a
country with vastly different ideals
in 2017 china entered a select club as
it opened a military base in djibouti
while four other countries have bases in
djibouti france italy japan and the us
this base was unique as it was china's
first base abroad
and those by themselves military bases
abroad
are unique only 15 of the world's most
developed and militarily powerful
countries worldwide have them
and now china is one of them although
western powers
might be worried for the wrong reasons
the government of china is clearly
putting a lot of focus and money into
africa
but not as much as you think based off
the result they're getting
vast amounts of influence over a whole
continent there are two key numbers to
look at
in 2015 china loaned just 12 billion
dollars to african countries
in the same year the country invested a
mere three billion dollars into the
continent
that's just not much but the reason
china is gaining this enormous
influence over the continent is because
the chinese government no longer has to
force this phenomenon
private chinese industry is taking hold
of africa
of the estimated 10 000 chinese
businesses in africa
90 of them are privately owned rather
than one of the numerous chinese
state-run companies
the chinese companies in africa are
actually making money
some substantially so the chinese
government certainly has provided a
considerable push to the
industrialization of africa
but now that that's done economic forces
are pushing the initiative further
forward
chinese small business is gripping the
continent much of the western world is
ignoring the prospects of the continent
ignoring that business in africa can now
be as profitable as business in china
was when its period of tremendous growth
began
right now africa is establishing itself
as the source of labor and resources for
china
and so until the west pays attention
africa will continue inching forward on
its path towards becoming
china's china one of the techniques used
to predict the gdp or gdp growth of a
country which is of course used to
decide which country to invest in
is machine learning for example here's
what a machine learning model predicted
a country's gdp would be over three
months
and here's what it actually was it
forecasted the country's gdp
far better than humans did the science
behind predictions like this
is complex but fascinating if you want
to learn how it works though
the best place to do so is brilliant.org
their machine learning course makes this
advanced concept simple
because their simple explanations
illuminating graphics and
thought-provoking questions
break a concept down into small packages
and then builds it back up to the final
result
they truly are experts in successfully
teaching complex topics
they also have plenty of other
fascinating courses on topics like
computational biology
number theory artificial neural networks
and more
you can start learning for free at
brilliance.org wendover
but then if you want to access the full
range of classes with their premium
subscription
the first 200 to use that link will also
get 20 off
their annual premium subscription thanks
for watching and we'll see you again
in three weeks for another wendover
productions video
you